yet to reach our first triple digit day
like we talked about but the heat can
still turn deadly for anyone inside a
hot car even in those 90s 8 news now
reporter Victoria Saha got an exclusive
look with the north Las Vegas fire
department as they show us how fast your
body can react to the heat in a locked
car
the desert heat can be intense
at your car it's worse it gets so hot in
these cars that these kids can't handle
it sometimes pails sometimes they're
flushed sometimes they get really red
skin they're they're really sweaty and
unfortunately sometimes we get there and
they're unconscious with a medic on
standby North Las Vegas firefighters
show
how just a few
car can turn dangerous the firefighters
just got inside the car and the
temperature was reading 123 degrees
I'm already hot his blood pressure was
dropping it's crazy because it's like
initially it wasn't bad but three
minutes in here you're like it's pretty
hot so far in about four minutes his
blood pressure's come down a few points
and his heart rate's gone up
by about 10 to 15 beats a minute so
physically uh definitely already taken a
toll we're now five minutes in and we're
going to check their temperature
101. I'm trying to sweat now oh it's
starting to get toasty it's not been 10
minutes we're gonna check their
temperature again
107. okay I don't think we can take much
more of this
way within three minutes I started
feeling the effects I felt my heart were
increasing I felt myself starting to
sweat and your body's just gonna keep
heating up you can't cool itself it only
took a few minutes for the firefighter
to feel sick now imagine if that was a
child or a pet left behind in a hot car
chances of survival are slim Victoria
Saha eight news now Victoria thanks now
the Medics telling Victoria the purpose
of the visual was to remind parents and
caretakers that you may think a quick
10-minute run into the store is okay it
is not it's not if there's a child left
in your car or an animal any amount of
time is not safe